ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dyan show it is uh we are deep into the
holiday season here um and it's the
holidays everywhere even in places where
things aren't going well so we have our
tree we have a beautiful tree with great
ornaments uh to celebrate this very
special and momentous time it is even
the holidays for hundra Biden who are uh
the president's son
uh in the
unending persecution of artists in
America they're trying to get him on
nine counts of tax
evasion this guy's got to remember to
not smoke
crack not [__]
hookers not leave blow in the White
House and pay your taxes it seems a
little lofty of an ideal to hold a human
being to that
standard there are so many things this
guy has to remember when he wakes up
don't call anyone I've ever met don't
reach out to any of the ex's don't call
my brother's ex who's my dead brother's
ex don't [__] her don't do that
again don't commit
a uh federal drug crime don't commit a
felony he's got a lot on his
plate and he's an
artist okay and many of you don't relate
to that because you are not
artists but he's an
artist Hunter Biden sees the world the
imperfections the terrible things and he
wants to make them into something
beautiful for you
that's what artists
do what's interesting about this is you
know Gavin Nome that snake had this done
because he wants to be the president so
he
directed his cronies in California to
charge Hunter Biden recovering addict
artist father
right father recovering addict artist
father son
of our president who's very present and
in the moment and not at all dead our
president and it's this is a beautiful
family that is now being attacked by the
silver tonged although not so silver
tonged in that debate with d santis
let's be honest Gavin got a little cocky
and kind of kind of [__] the bed
um but I can't believe that they got
this
guy on tax
evasion Hunter Biden was indicted on
nine tax charges in California as a
special Council investigation into the
business dealings of President Joe
Biden's son intensifies against the
backdrop of the 2024
election they cannot get Biden to quit
this is the thing he won't quit I don't
know if it's him that won't quit maybe
it is
him the every poll that is being
released is basically like you cannot
run you cannot
walk you you you can't do it you're
going to
lose you're putting us at a big
disadvantage in the general
election they have him matched up
against Trump anyone Des santed dead
people Biden always comes out the loser
by like 10
points so now I think they've
basically now they're going to basically
see like well let let's see how much we
can leak on his son because this guy
won't leave and I don't know why he
won't leave what did he
do what did this guy what are they
afraid of the next person
finding this is the only thing I've
cooked up in my own head and I may not
be
correct what are they afraid
of why will he not leave what what do
they not
want the next person stumbling upon why
would he even want this gig why do you
even want the
job so now Hunter his the only son he
has
left three felonies six
misdemeanors in addition of federal
firearms charges in Delaware alleging
Hunter Biden broke laws against drug
users having guns in
2018 why shouldn't a drug user have guns
Del aware they need them drug users need
them more than regular
people they come after the implosion of
a plea deal over the summer that would
have spared him jail time putting the
case on track to a possible trial as his
father campaigns for reelection well
there it
is Biden's campaigning for re-election
the hunter Biden
trial he spent millions of dollars on an
extravagant lifestyle rather than paying
his tax bills
yeah so
what they say he ow 1.4 million in taxes
because between 2016 and 2019 he wasn't
paying his taxes he was smoking
crack but the back taxes have since been
paid so I don't understand what the
problem is if convicted he could face a
maximum of 17 years in prison
based on the facts of the law if
Hunter's last name was anything other
than Biden the Chargers in Delaware now
California would not have been brought
LEL
said here's a thing I would almost argue
the opposite it's like nobody's had more
leniency kind of than this
guy think about this this guy is the son
of the
president he has videos of himself
smoking crack and holding guns to
escorts
heads we're kind of chill about this
we've been pretty chill about it you
know like everybody's kind of been chill
it hasn't been like like obviously the
Republicans have you know been like hey
man you suppressed that story the laptop
which they did it's a fact they didn't
want that story out but people have been
kind of chill
here about the content which is like
this guy was wild like I'm sure Roger
Clinton was Wild Bill Clinton's brother
and Neil
Bush but we just don't have photo and
video evidence of every [__] up thing
they've ever done with this guy I mean
you can see him smoking crack guns to
the heads of hookers can we get any of
that up that we can play without be it
being a problem uh some of is in scrubed
I can find some for what's what's
interesting about it is people are like
well he's being attacked cuz his name is
Biden it's like no no no one could do
that if my aunt found my uncle's laptop
and he had even one of the videos that
Hunter Biden had his whole life would be
ruined can you imagine that if anyone
found think to
yourself you have a laptop maybe in uh I
don't know your SP
room your wife finds it your husband
your significant other other your kids
they find a laptop on the laptop is
photos and videos of you smoking crack
with
hookers in the
Ukraine
anyone anyone's life would have been
ruined this guy is doing well he's
painting he lived in Malibu up until
recently still does this guy's doing
great there's no way my uncle could have
a laptop with photos and videos of him
doing the things Hunter Biden did and
end up in Malibu no way no way no one no
one if you recorded every bad thing
you've ever done [__] hookers guns to
their head lines of coke cooking
crack if you recorded every single thing
you've ever done you're life would be
ruined over your wife would divorce you
she would take everything the judge
would be like buddy what the [__] you'd
go into the rehab you could potentially
be charged with something I don't
know
documents texts and videos obtained by
Daily Mail show Hunter Biden spent a
staggering 30,000 on escorts in a
five-month period by the way 30,000 in
five months you can do that
that's not that stagger I mean it's wa I
mean come on he's not these aren't
bottom of the barrel [__] here he's
got he's got good [__] mhm but can you
imagine that if you spent
$30,000 on escorts in five
months and recorded the entire thing and
then your wife found it you would be DOA
dead he's doing pretty good he's still
at the White House they still let him in
the white house he still gets to stand
on the the balcony he's probably still
leaving cocaine in the white
house he had an AR didn't Hunter Biden
have like a show of his work yeah it was
here in SoHo yeah he had a show of his
work in
SoHo this is not a guy who's like a
hopeless guy people well well it's he's
being persecuted because of his name no
no no no no it's his name which is the
reason that the guy can live in Malibu
and have art shows in SoHo no regular
human being can spend
872 th000 on prostitutes porn and sex
club memberships take 1.6 million from
ATMs by the way it's a job as father got
him in the burisma [__] around in the
Ukraine that's how he has all this
money he's a lawyer lawyers don't have
any money anymore by the way anyone
listening to this thinking about
becoming a lawyer when you graduate law
school now you're you're impoverished
for like 15 years you can't make any M
there's like 20 lawyers that have any
money it's not a lucrative thing anymore
doctors same thing you talk to the big
real estate agents you go who did you
represent 20 30 years ago they go it was
doctors lawyer they go now I don't have
one doctor one lawyer they can't afford
[__] it's all Tech Finance creative
people on a very high level and athletes
lawyers and doctors are out this guy's a
lawyer
how the [__] he taken
1.6 out of an ATM it's because he had a
[__] job where there was a slush fund
which he used for hookers and blow and
by the way I'm not even moralizing about
any of that I've had my own problems I'm
not more like I'm not saying that this
guy should be
condemned I'm saying he's getting less
than what a normal person would get I
sat in uh AA for years I still do
occasionally uh it's not Anonymous when
it's my program I keep other people's
anonymity I don't give a [__] whether
you know what I'm in or not I don't go
enough I should go more but I've heard
stories of how people's lives Get
Wrecked when they do what he's done I've
lived them right I lost a house my
credit got shredded I lived with comics
on couches in rooms in New York City for
years working [__] jobs trying to learn
how to be funny there was no art gallery
show in SoHo there were no high-end
rehabs I didn't live in
malibo I wasn't invited to the White
House that was not part of my sobering
up
journey I had tax problems too I had to
pay the [__] money I had to get a
shitty little lawyer that didn't really
care who tried their best and we paid
the [__] money back I didn't really
owe that much money he owed a lot more
than me but this idea that like Hunter
Biden's had it particularly rough is
insane that's
insane it's crazy he's not had it
particularly rough I know tons of
addicts whose entire lives and they
didn't do a fraction of what he
did I know people who lost their entire
lives because they drank too much one
night and got in a car and got pulled
over didn't hurt anyone didn't kill
anyone didn't have uh you know 200
videos of Ukrainian human trafficking
victims [__] them with a gun to their
head they just made a left when they
shouldn't have they got pulled over they
lost their car they lost their job they
had to pay restitution they they didn't
have the money for it it took them years
to get their lives back
years so this idea that the Democrats
are going to be like well it's
actually Hunter is paying a price that
other people don't pay he's paying far
less of a price than any drug addict
ever that's been caught with anything
and no matter what you believe
politically I don't care if you love Joe
Biden and hate Donald Trump you have to
agree if you're a rational person that
Hunter Biden is not paying the price
that other people have paid how many
drug addicts by the way
are in
Malibu with an art show in
SoHo and I mean this is wild so Hunter's
four years of wild
spending he went nuts spending money
ATM's
1.6 2016 he withdrew
200,000 this is by the way a lesson in
Progressive uh drug use as well and how
it gets worse 2016 200 Grand 2016's
probably not that bad he's smoking crack
occasionally couple of lines of the
powdered cocena it's okay things aren't
great but it could be
worse
53,000 out of an ATM now he's not taking
this money out to tip
valet understand this money goes right
to the dealer I know I was a drug addict
from many years that's why when I'm
talking about him I'm not condemning the
act of using drugs I'm condemning this
idea that he's had it particularly rough
he hasn't 500,000 in 2017
2018 things get a little
unmanageable
$772,000 at of ATM or cash withdrawal
where he shows
up sniffling at a bank and goes I I got
to take some some money out I need some
money now and he goes in he's got a nice
suit because he spent a lot of money on
clothes that's the next thing coming
up clothing and accessories he spent a
total over this and so the last year at
772 548 the exact same amount of money
so that's where he maxed out that's
where he was going to die he was doing
about
$800,000 worth of crack a
year around that and
hookers hookers and crack that 800,000
of hookers and crack that was his budge
that was the budget in 2019 you're
telling me you spent 800,000 on hookers
and crack two years in a row you have a
art show in SoHo no and nobody I know no
one you know by the I'm talking about
celebrities I'm talking about a lot of
people I'm not just talking about broke
people or middle class people I'm
talking about like people that I know
that have done really really well if
they had behaved like that it would be
over over over there would be no second
or third act this guy's got the benefit
of his second or third Act and the only
and if he is being which he's not if
this is all
political and that's the only reason
that they're doing this and obviously
Nome may be involved in it trying to get
him out I don't know if he is or not it
doesn't make Newsome look great either
by the way to to to show that this is
you know this he keeps talking about how
great Biden is this is his son
if he is being if any of this is
politically motivated it's because his
dad won't just not be the
president his dad won't just walk away
and let someone else
run so but I don't think it is like
here's the deal he's a known guy so he's
he's
being prosecuted because they know what
he did whether it's political or not
they they know know what he did the
crimes are public they're out in the
open he didn't pay the taxes so this
idea that like you
know my favorite one is Health Beauty
and
Pharmacy in 2016 he spent 54,000 2017 he
spent
110,000 2018 46,000
2019 uh less 26,000 on health beautyy
2019 he's like listen no condoms anymore
the condom budget's done we don't need
condoms honey you don't need tweezers
and Q-tips it doesn't matter no
condoms that's the only one that goes
down is Health Beauty and Pharmacy you
don't need Claritin get in the car get
in the
car you know 2016 is's really nice about
it he's like yeah go get go get whatever
you want get whatever you want what do
you what what do you need you want I've
all you girls love your nails go in
there and get nail nail polish remover
whatever you need I'll be in the car you
go in there and get whatever you want
2019 he knows these [__] for a while
he's like you get in the [__] car
okay you know I'm clean we don't need a
condom you know I'm
clean my father's [__] gonna be the
president um so that sucks but we wish
we wish what do we wish him we wish him
well wish them well I'm telling you
right now I I I I so many people are
doing e-commerce right now and so many
people are unfortunately unaware of ship
station and the reality is ship station
is something that is so essential
especially for a new business or even
for an established one don't get stuck
worrying about shipping orders let ship
station do the heavy lifting so you and
your team can put your time money energy
into more important things when it comes
to those inevitably inevitable holiday
returns ship station automates
recommends exchanges and gathers
customer feedback so even if they bought
the wrong size or color they'll have a
great experience whether you're shipping
from your house or multiple Warehouse
ship station can increase your holiday
profitability you could quickly and
easily update crucial order information
reducing errors effortless integration
with Amazon Etsy eBay Shopify and more
ship station manages orders prints
labels Compares rates here's what's
amazing about ship station they handle
your entire back office you put the time
and effort and energy into what you need
to which is the creative end generating
clients marketing you know the
origination of ideas right that's what
powers a business the sales end over
130,000 companies have scaled their
e-commerce business with ship station
98% of companies that use it for a year
become customers for life get discounts
up to 84% off USPS and UPS rates this is
what I love you get a free 60-day trial
so basically you get 60 days free trial
using this service if you use code Tim
Dylan go to shipstation.com code Tim
Dyan everybody buys [__] on the internet
I don't care what you're doing you live
in Tennessee an area you got some fun
looking acorns and stuff sell them on
the Internet sell anything on the
internet old lunchboxes people that buy
them on the internet if you want to go
to craft I mean Gary ve talks about this
stuff all the time and he's never wrong
if you go to Old weird craft stores and
[__] you buy [__] sell it on the
internet how are you going to do it
shipstation 60-day free trial
shipstation.com code Tim Dylan
shipstation.com code Tim Dillan it's
more important than ever right now to be
healthy
and if you want farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients seasonal recipes delivered
right to your door skip trips to the
grocery store especially now during the
holidays it is packed go to hellofresh
make home cooking easy fun and
affordable that's why you know these
Frozen things when you get them they're
never the same it's never the same
that's why you need a meal
kit you want a Stressless holiday season
with the help of hellofresh get the
grocery store save time with easy Tasty
Recipes is delivered right to your door
it's so easy you make these 10-minute
lunches so easy fresh food never Frozen
delivered to you you cook it easy you
you want a date nice date is making a
dinner with somebody let this person
that you've just invited into your life
see that you value yourself your health
cooking being home people like that I'm
telling you it's such a big deal right
now to show a potential partner mother
or father of your child that you really
value eating food at home and being
healthy after a full day of work there's
so much to do hellofresh is great it's
great for families it's great for single
people we use it I use it all of my
friends are really using it now and
we're all very excited it excites
us I'll call someone I go what are you
doing they go cooking hellofresh and and
but when they say it there's something
in their voice they it's nice they're
happy they go I'm they say I'm cooking
hell FR but it's not as crazy as that
it's it's more of I'm I'm cooking hello
fres it's look like they're in a musical
or something and you could just hear it
maybe they're chopping a little onion or
putting something in a pan um it's so
easy go to hellofresh.com
timd free use the code timd free t m DF
re e e for free breakfast for life are
you [__] nuts
this is what they're giving if you don't
do this you're crazy timd free free
breakfast for Life One breakfast item
per box while subscription is active
that's free breakfast for L you don't
have to pay for breakfast are you
listening are you listening are you
listening King
Tutt it's the ornament Tim D free free
breakfast for light with you
nuts
McDonald's America needs in what I've
always said is where are we I always say
that as a country go where are we what
do we need where are we what do we need
these are the things that keep me up at
night I go where are we what do we need
and you know what we need we need more
McDonald's that's our
medicine we need more McDonald's the
prescription for what this country needs
is more McDonald's in a slightly
different because look at what
McDonald's has
done it's a
legendary concept originating where all
good things do in
California where you can get
cheeseburgers for almost nothing
whenever you
want that's what McDonald's is it's
other things yes it's Grimace and the
Hamburg it's fun they have the play
place the McGriddle is nice but it's
it's the beginning of fast food the idea
and the concept that someone
somewhere is going to hand you a hot
cheeseburger through a window
immediately pretty much whenever you
want that is one of the most
revolutionary
Concepts in American history you may
think we've abused that concept and
there's certainly some idence I've
abused it I know my friends have abused
it but that is what McDonald's is
McDonald's is now launching A New
Concept it's being launched in Bowling
Brook or balling Brook Illinois Bowling
Brook Illinois it's called cosmics cosos
smc's it's not open yet there was a team
full of actors in the drive through
filling a uh filming a commercial so the
menu was up and I was able to snap a few
picks from afar
it's a a mix of a lot of new drink
offerings and an all day breakfast menu
of new items so here's what McDonald's
has realized they look at Starbucks and
they
go Starbucks is killing people with
drinks it's much easier look look at any
Starbucks there's not a lot of people
working in a Starbucks it's a pretty
paired down
concept you can kill PE a good amount of
people it's a real genocide with
Frappuccinos in there you can kill them
easily you need a blender some syrup
some ice and a lid that's it you don't
need grills and onions and cheeseburgers
you don't need hash browns you don't
need little apple slices to pretend to
give to the kids and all that [__]
you don't need characters you don't need
all you need you don't need a fry cook
all you need is a couple marginal
intelligent reasonably desperate people
to work there all day Manning the
they're all versions of a
slushie the the maligned thing that we
all hated at 7-Eleven we all made fun of
because it is
heinous the Quicky Mart slushie from The
Simpsons the the just cold slush in your
uh
glass is what a frappuccino is now of
course it tastes better it's got
caffeine it's coffee it's sugar but
that's what Starbucks does you know yes
they do coffee they do other things well
what about the paninis yeah sure sure
but what they do is every month at
Starbucks they have a new way to kill
you they have a caramel macchiato with
toasted coconut they have a mocha cookie
crumble they have a it's a milkshake
it's all it is and they have holiday
they have a a caramel Brule peppermint
mocha you know
and what these things do is they're
addictive you ever had a frappuccino I
have you drive through the third sip I
may get one after this just hearing
myself talk about it the third sip or
fourth sip of a
frappuccino your eyes open your your
headache if you have a tiny little
headache it goes away you make that
right
turn onto the [__] uh you know onto
the service road or the parkway or the
highway and you are doing good and you
put it in the cup holder and maybe
there's a song that Mar I don't want to
laugh and and and and you were just you
are on you're riding the horse of sugar
and it tastes good and now I used to do
with little perad dooodle do I'd have a
perco set and you put a marar Al light
in your mouth or Newport or Marboro
light oh Lord
Jesus Oh Lord and then the [__] that
would just gather in your stomach that
you would take at the office and you
would spend the first 10 minutes in the
office [__] that glorious per ccoet
Starbucks cigarette
[__] now when you have when you have an
office job these are the small lovely
pleasantries we talked about a couple
episodes
back so what McDonald's has realized
because all these Executives sit around
and they basically go how do we kill
people how do we kill them how do we do
it how do we kill people and PE the
McDonald's goes you know they're coming
after red meat yeah they don't like that
they're saying that the cows farting is
killing the ozone layer everybody's
getting skin cancer the waters are going
to rise going to be a real Day After
Tomorrow situation you know Miami
Manhattan all these places flooded
California's on fire not good
uh we don't like it not good so they go
we got to figure out
how to transition out of red meat this
is what McDonald's I truly believe they
thought like this because they're smart
they're not dumb they're
smart and they go how do we kill people
make that big this is how you kill
people this is how you kill people with
a churo
frappe churo frae s'mores cold brew this
is how you kill people
this is how you kill people in a world
that has turned against red meat we've
turned against a cheeseburger red meat's
a symbol of the patriarch you don't give
a [__] about anything I be I bet you hit
trans people with a
stick so the churo frae comes the
s'mores cold brew can you imagine
that the sour cherry energy burst for
the
minorities there's got to be something
for them there's nothing wrong with it
tropical what is that that say spice Aid
looks a little like [__] aid but I
that's theirs that's what they it's
spice Aid blueberry Ginger burst for the
people who are like I just need a little
cleansing today black berry mint green
tea Island pick me up punch
oo Berry hibiscus sour Aid popping pear
slush popping pear slush s Tango
lemonade chai frappe burst turmeric
spice life so now what they'll do they
do this and then they also have like a
green tea it's just like McDonald's has
the
salad here's how you kill people and by
the way if you don't think I'm going to
uh Bowling Brook
Illinois in like a day you're crazy
because
I this does look phenomenal now but this
is they are trying to kill you and
knowing that is okay because everybody
hates cynicism Conan O'Brien who I think
is a brilliant comedian who I respect
and love and everything he's done I love
but he said one day there one moment I
had a little disagreement with him but
he is such a iconic legendary guy that
you just everything he says he goes yeah
I I bet he parts of what he's saying I
understand where he goes I hate cynicism
it's my least favorite emotion and it
doesn't produce anything
good I understand what he's saying and
where he's coming from but I've always
valued little bit of cynicism and I'll
tell you why it can keep you alive and
it can keep you um it can keep you from
getting in
trouble too
much delusion isn't
good um
ascribing motives to people that are
positive isn't good oh you don't know
why someone's trying to help you you
don't know why it could be because
they're a lovely amazing person and they
just get off on helping people if might
be because they like the position that
they're in versus the one that you're in
they might like that Dynamic of being
kind of above you they might want to
control you there's all kinds of reasons
and I'm not saying you shouldn't take
help or you should be overly paranoid
but
like especially when it comes to
American corporations I think maybe a
little bit of citiis when it comes to
narratives about War and Peace a little
bit of cynicism when uh a a new credit
card is launched where they go it's no
money to no interest you're the winner
you know 27 months no payment like be a
little cynical about these things um so
when McDonald's goes we're gonna open
this New Concept be a little cynical
they're trying to kill you they have
something called mck
pops they're little Donuts filled with
peanut butter and Nutella they have a
spicy queso sandwich creamy avocado
tomatillo sandwich prenzel bites Egg
McMuffins McFlurries caramel fudge
brownie Sunday's cookies caramel fudge
brownie The Twist cone Savory hash brown
bites but make no mistake the star of
the menu will be the drinks that is what
they want they're trying to kill you now
primarily with liquid it is easier they
can make it easier it's cheaper it gets
you addicted you're addicted and you go
[__] it I want a s'mores cold
brew that's how I want to start my day
with a churo
frae and and when when they come out
with the nutrition information and
what's in these make no mistake these
will be it will be a cup of poison it
will
be sugar do they have any of it I'm
looking for it right now let's see if we
can find any of it you want to see the
churro wi first let's see the churro
frappe
first what is the churro frappe working
with in terms
of 610 calories only 610 calories for
for a drink 610 calories under n churo
frappe yeah do we have the breakdown of
sugar uh not
yet it's proprietary they're not going
to give out ingredients yeah they're not
going right okay so this is a new it by
the way it represents a shift fast food
over the next months weeks years is
going to move away from red meat they're
going to move away into things that feel
healthy that are
not this is what's going to happen
McDonald's is the most powerful and
biggest company the fact that they're
doing a drink restaurant shows you that
the future is probably going to be in in
things like
that they can kill you in many different
ways they don't need to kill you the way
they've always killed you they can end
your life
slowly in many different ways and the
way that they're going to do it is by
opening a Starbucks for people that film
fight videos after school because that's
who goes to McDonald's a lot of people
McDonald's knows where their locations
are yes some of them are in the suburbs
some of them are in the city the
interstate and what are you going to
drink when a [__] pops off to another
[__] and they start beating each other
and 30 kids with iPhones are filming it
you know what you're going to drink a
popping Paar
slush as they wipe the blood off the
floor of the Bronx Grand Concourse
McDonald's you were going to hear the
slurp of a churro frae being finished
finished at
Cosmic when the bloody floor of a cosmic
is being cleaned with ammonia by an
immigrant who doesn't speak English
someone will have a cold Bruce
s'mores and you'll hear the clink of the
ice this is marketed to people that just
want to get high it's about getting high
and McDonald's is like we just need to
run these do we have any art or any
renderings of what these will look like
inside uh here we go where will people
drink the sour cherry energy burst or
the tropical spice Aid where will they
drink
that when you were typing free Palestine
on to X you'll be drinking a tropical
spice
a no insides yet just no ins sides yet
blue and yellow very interesting so th
this is coming this is coming it's Sonic
it looks like Sonic well what they're
trying to do is they're trying to move
away from what they've made their money
doing which is beef and red meat and
they know
that the people that are still into red
meat are are are people that are going
oh it has benefits keto carnivore
whatever obviously poor people still eat
burgers but it's that vast middle people
that don't have enough money for a RI
eye that's
grass-fed and they're not totally [__]
with they're just eating White Castle
it's that vast middle class that they're
the ones we try everything out on
they're the ones we go we yell at them
all the time you know don't use too much
toilet paper how how long are you in the
shower for it's the middle the rich do
whatever they want and the poor just try
to survive the middle class they're the
ones we try out all our [__] on every
Guilt Trip gets delivered directly to
the doors of the middle class usually by
the rich they go this is what you should
care about you mouthbreather
so the middle class right now they're
being beaten down by don't eat red meat
red meat's bad climate change red meat
climate change boom boom but every
article every article that the times is
putting out the New Yorker even the
journal Wall Street Journal all of these
Publications are putting out the idea
that red meat draw a line to climate
change draw a line to we're all flooded
and dead that burger draw a line to your
mouth and rich people don't give a [__]
they go they own all the [__] that's
poisoning the planet they don't care and
poor people are like I have $3 what do
you want me to do I have $3 I gotta eat
I got an eight hour shift I've been
broke I was a tour guide in New York
City when I got off I had Dollar Pizza I
had no money what was I going to do have
a wild caught salmon for $38 it's not
GNA happen you don't have a lot of time
when you're poor you're broke here's the
hot thing that's cheap for you
you so what McDonald's is smartly
realizing is that this middle class that
they still have to try to lure into
their restaurants they have to lure the
middle class into their restaurants
along with the lower class that's why
they have the you know all the tropical
spicy I mean that's being aimed at
people that don't have a lot of money
and then they have the blueberry green
tea this is green tea habiscus this is
the habiscus green tea you know they
have all of those
things because those things are
um aimed and targeted at kind of the
little white you know the white woman
who's having a
hibiscus and I went to cosmics I have my
habiscus
blueberry green tea and man I I wish
Hamas would just tie me to a tree I
think about just a couple of Arab men
tie me to the back of a truck I just sit
there with my habiscus
tea and I sexualize monster terrorists
because I'm bored
Bo and that's what you know this is what
Cosmic cosmc is going to
do but it does represent kind of that
significant shift in what fast food has
to do because this is they have to lure
you in they have to hit you over the
head and Americans you know it's the uh
it's that old adage right it's like the
the rich the poor kind of get away but
it's the middle class that we we
experiment on it's an
experiment feeding people sugar like
this is an experiment and we're going to
experiment on the lab brats in the
American suburbs that's why this is
happening in Bowling Brook Illinois we
go this isn't happening in Malibu
they're not doing this on Park Avenue in
Manhattan they're doing it in Bowling
Brook Illinois they're like when you get
off work at the plant whatever plants
even left or you're on your way to be a
fifth grade teacher you want to stop at
cosmics and get a churro frappe to just
give
yourself the the buzz the sugar high to
stare at these children and get through
the
day that's really what it comes down to
you know I everyone's going to I went to
an event the other night at Broadway
show it's so good to get out there and
see live stuff concerts sporting events
comedy shows Broadway shows theater you
just want to get out there how do you do
it I use the game time app I got the
best tickets we were like the third row
Orchestra was amazing was amazing game
time is the only ticketing app that
gives you complete peace of mind with
your
purchase
God I'm telling you if you're not using
the game time app I don't get it because
it's so hard these different you know
you don't know people go am I getting
ripped off all the time people buy
tickets at my shows they go why are they
so expensive I go you're using the wrong
thing you're not going directly to the
source it's so difficult you want the
tickets you want them now you want to
pay a good price you don't want to get
hosed it's the game time app it's easy
they have deals on tickets right up to
the start of the event and even an hour
after it starts they want to fill last
minute seats you get so many good
deals football basketball baseball
concerts comedy theater more download
the game time app create an account use
code Tim for $20 off your first purchase
I'm telling you I use this now I go to a
lot of things I take friends to things
it is the only way it is the easiest way
to just get great tickets to anything
it's such an easy interface easy to use
it's really
good if you find tickets in the same
section and row for last game time
will'll credit you% of the difference
that's how confident they are that
really they you're not GNA find that
you're not gonna find it okay they've
done their work you're not gonna find it
what you think you're gonna find it
you're not why don't you let them do
what they're good at and you do what
you're good at sitting on your
ass download the game time app create an
account use the code Tim for $20 off
your first purchase terms apply again
create an account and redeem code t for
$20 off download game time today last
minute tickets lowest price
guaranteed everybody's trying to protect
themselves online from the government or
from people but these these hackers or
these people that are buying your data
selling your data harvesting your data
your banking information identity theft
expressvpn is the move we all have it
and love it and use it it works on all
of my devices whether I'm on my phone
tablet laptop whatever I'm is protected
best of all Express VPN is super easy to
use all I do is tap one button and turn
it on and I'm
protected this holiday season give
yourself the gift of privacy if you're
not using a VPN you're behind the times
because everybody is and it's a great
way to protect yourself most of us are
doing more and more online our banking
Our dating our living so how are we
going to protect ourselves you have a
door on your house don't
you do you have a door well if you have
a door take yourself off the naughty
list with the number one VPN go to
expressvpn.com Tim Dillan that's
expressvpn.com Tim Dillan if you have a
door on your house if you don't have a
door on your house then don't do it
because you live dangerously but if you
have a [__] door on your house or
apartment if you have a door go to
expressvpn.com Tim Dillan this helps the
show supporting our sponsors helps our
show but it really helps you I don't
need you you need expressvpn because I
do need you a little but here's
expressvpn you go oh my God oh my God
this is what happens when you don't use
expressvpn you want to hear oh my honey
where's our
son our son where is he he was crying a
minute ago while I was fixing our
tree oh I don't hear him anymore well
maybe go check on him
oh my God what are you saying our son
has been stolen our baby
son how did people know we had a baby
son and where we lived is it honey did
you not get expressvpn I no I'm not mad
I'm asking you I'm asking you I'm not
mad I'm asking you if you got expressvpn
or if you didn't and now that's why our
son has been stolen the namesake the air
the person who's going to carry on my
name did you get look me in the eye you
didn't and that's why we have a stolen
son so that's what happen see this is
what you want to avoid
that do you want to avoid that and if
you want to avoid that if you want to
avoid literally your children being
stolen go to
expressvpn.com Tim Dillan
expressvpn.com Tim Dillan everybody's in
the holiday season trying to get lucky
here's how you get lucky always be ready
with blue.com blue has the same active
ingredients as viagara and seis at a
fraction of the cost it is shipped to
your home in a very discreet package
you're not going to be embarrassed you
don't have to go to the doctor the
pharmacy long lines waiting one of the
specialists at Blue will will basically
go through everything with you it's very
easy they're made in the USA these
tablets are prepared and shipped direct
to your door in a discrete package we've
got a great deal for the listeners here
try blueo free when you use our promo
code TD at checkout that's $5 shipping
try it see what happens you'll have the
best sex of your life maybe even just by
yourself but it'll be great blue.com
promo code TD to receive your first
month free blue.com promo Cod
TD it's got to be ready you got to be
ready it's Readiness Readiness Readiness
be aware be ready be ready for action
how be it your best prime how do you
stay prime blueo it is a chewable tablet
that makes your penis hard if you don't
understand that I'm saying as plainly as
I can chewable tablet oh look at my PP
is hard
now you want a hard PP go to blue.com
promo code TD receive your first month
free you're being treated like a
Rockefeller sitting there with your free
dick pills promo code TD blue.com
TD I want to talk about this drug dealer
that Trump let out he they released
under Trump they charged him uh on an
assault on
teenager a drug dealer who was released
under former president Donald Trump's
sweeping Criminal Justice Reform has
been charged with first-degree assault
of a
teenager William deden dreaden was
indicted along with his wife Tiffany
Harrison in connection with their
alleged involvement in assault outside
of Baltimore High School
uhoh authorities said that the comple
accompanied their 15-year-old son to the
Carver Vocational Technical High School
on October 27th and allegedly joined
their son son in the assault of another
teenager during which their son pistol
whipped uh the victim well listen do you
want parents to be involved in their
kids' lives or
not do you want people invested in what
their kids are doing or not yes or yes
if I'm going to pistol whip someone at
my high school and my father and mother
come with me and attack that person
that's a family memory I'll have for the
rest of my
life
I don't know what's going on in these
inner city schools we always hear about
them there's issues I imagine but I'll
tell you this everyone always says the
parents are not involved this is what we
hear all the time the parents are Mia
they're not around the kids are are
running around doing all their own stuff
well here is a a situation where a
father and a
mother decide to go to the school with
their son to pistle whip someone and you
know what
I think it's nice I think it's actually
good I think it's pretty [__] nice
that a couple of weeks before Christmas
someone that Trump let out of jail with
his wife goes to support their son in a
pistol whipping I think it's
nice he secured early release from
federal prison for isn't this good
letting everyone out of jail I think
it's great it seems to be working well
this no bail seems to be working well
where you commit a crime and they ask
nicely not to again it seems well it
seems great it seems like it's a good
idea to just let everyone out of jail I
don't know I don't
know dreaden and Harrison each face 15
charges including first-degree assault
reckless endangerment and use of a fire
firearm in the commission of a crime of
violence records show that dreaden had
secured early release from federal
prison 14 months before the October
incident after making a claim under the
first step act which was the most
important Criminal Justice Reform
legislation passed in a decade Baltimore
Police told Newsweek that dreaden had
previously been arrested multiple times
for drug rated charges Dre's criminal
history is first reported by Baltimore
TV the bipartisan legislation which
aimed to cut unnecessarily long Federal
sentences and improve conditions of
federal prisons was widely supported by
both Democrats and Republicans
lovely although Trump ran a tough on
crime campaign when he was elected to
the White House in 2016 here's the
problem see here's what it is here's
what it is here's what it is we all
think it's unfair that people that sold
drugs have to spend their entire lives
in
prison we all pretty much think
that nonviolent drug offenders um end up
[__] with these you know Federal
mandatory minimum sentences Rockefeller
drug laws in New York in example you
know these are not great
um however not every everyone and I'm
gonna and I'm going to you know people
aren't going to love
this people aren't going to love this
because this is not nice to hear are you
ready for this get ready listen closely
listen closely pull pull over pull into
cosmics get your frae get ready for this
not all nonviolent drug offenders are
gonna be
nonviolent I
know bummer bummer not all nonviolent
drug offenders can be is just what it is
just what it is some of them will be
some of them are some of them are lovely
and great and they got caught up and
whatever but some of them are going to
pistol whip a 15-year-old at
school I don't know I don't know what
you
know part of freedom is going with your
son to pistol whip the kid at school I
guess and you know I guess you know
you're going to get arrested for that
but you know a lot of this criminal J
Justice Reform like let's make the
prison safer and nicer and it's all
needed we need better prisons and that
rehabilitate people and don't just throw
them into these boxes you know all these
cosos just start fight clubs uh with the
people which is a decent way to stay in
shape and you know fighting is now more
mainstream and everybody loves it so I
don't know why they are always you know
everybody's always like they started a
Fight Club it's like well it's you
know but here's my point my point is
this there should be more
rehabilitative uh you know
programs in prison people come out of
prison they don't know what to
do but this is also going to happen you
if you fling open the gates of prisons
and let people out some of them are
going to go to the school and pistol
whip the kids with their children now
again I don't this is a this is a
family that has chosen to act together
that's not nothing this is kind of nice
we always hear about the inner cities
that the families are not together I'm
not making that up this is what we hear
I don't I'm not involved by the way so
don't come at me and be like this is
coded racist it's not it's not I'm I
hear that there are issues in the inner
cities with the families not being
together I hear it I'm not experiencing
it this is not the case this isn't the
case this is a father and mother who
love their child enough to go to jail
for him by because they pistol whipped a
15-year-old and Donald Trump let them
out of jail to appear for whatever
reason I don't know Donald Trump W
trying to secure the rapper vote I guess
I don't know he had some of it
already and Coulter and a lot of his
people that really loved him were like
what are you doing here what is this why
why is this
happening but you
know here's the deal in a in a in a in a
bubble this is kind of fine if it wasn't
the prevailing attitude of all the inner
city to just fling up in jail CES and
let everybody out if there was a a way
to look at this in a bubble and you go
yeah this [__] happens this is a perfect
[__] happen
story and the people that are pro the
reforms will say it [__] happens it's
amazing what is and isn't [__] happens
by the way if a girl at college is
sexually assaulted by a white guy it's
not [__] happens it is a
orwellian structure that has oppressed
and there's all of that but if something
like this Happ it's not [__] happens
this is uh you know I'm sorry this one
would be should Happ this one would be
like well hey you know people they have
a bad morning some of them have a bad
morning and they just pistol whip their
son's enemy at
school so it really just depends it's
both sides do it Republicans do [__]
happens Democrats do [__]
happens part of our
country is deciding what isn't what
isn't isn't [__] happens that's part of
the whole country that's part of the
entire thing is it [__] happens when
this happens or is it you made that [__]
happen or [__] is happening for a reason
that you could potentially uh change
fix
alleviate this burden somehow and I'm no
expert on any of this stuff it is just
it is interesting because this is what
everybody believes now I go out with
people I talk to people I chat with
people we all talk and they go it's the
criminal justice system in America is
corrupt it's unfair those things aren't
untrue and it's certainly been cruel to
African-Americans certainly been cruel
to Inner City certainly it is a all of
that is true no one's denying
that the problem then
becomes how do you fix it without
destroying Public
Safety that's that's the issue it's not
easy it's not an easy thing to do how do
you fix it without people pistol
whipping 15y olds at the school which
again I don't know if I'm against or for
I don't know what the kid
did I'm just saying that's the concern
how do you fix
it without
destroying Public Safety they didn't
they it doesn't seem to be working in
San Fran doesn't it's not really working
in La more home invasions now than there
have been go to any party had a
Christmas party in La people just you
know they come in they a house on my
block was robbed or you know a guy got
followed home I got a got a gun to that
no nobody in La is that creative to make
this stuff up by the way if they did the
shows would be better they're not that
creative this actually happened you can
hear what's going on in an area by just
talking talking to people it's no
conspiracy No Agenda these are all
liberals by the way they're Los Angeles
liberals in the entertainment business
none of them follow it up by the way
with we need harsher penalty because
they're too dumb they don't even
understand what's going on they just
tell you what they see my friend got
followed home gun to his head they took
his Lamborghini and then some of them
now have started to go yeah maybe we
need a maybe people need to go to jail a
little bit but you know this this idea
that
you can just let everybody
out might not work nobody is willing to
admit this is my favorite thing about
politicians they're all certain of the
of the results of everything they do
none of them go yeah we don't know we
don't know none of them everybody goes
this will reduce the no one has no one
has the foresight to go yeah we don't
you know there be a be a mixed bag out
there be a mixed bag bag out there if we
if we let everybody out some people will
live lovely lives very productive lives
and a few people will pistol whip kids
at school we don't know we don't know we
don't know you can't sell that to PE you
couldn't sell that to people you can't
so you just have to go you know you have
to go well this will reduce the
unfair treatment the you know and you go
okay well people go yeah yeah yeah that
sounds good I don't want people treat it
unfairly and then the flip side of that
is oh you maybe you're tied up in the
house some of those people that support
a lot of this stuff are and it is kind
of funny to be tied up in belir it's
just funny it's not not
funny it is human comedy you support a
lot of this stuff and to be tied up you
know you're in a chair and Bel Air and
they've tied you up and you're sitting
there and you were like one of those
people all in you were all in for this
you were all in for letting everybody
out and you go I'm was in for what what
happening
and then you're tied up in the chair
there there's an element of Comedy to
that and I hope the people that are tied
up realize that I hope they can laugh at
it I hope they can enjoy it for the
irony that it is it is an irony irony's
abound a lot of people were anti-id
vaccines and then they got covid and
died now maybe the vaccine would not
have helped them I don't know but
there's an irony to that a little bit
there's certainly irony to people that
believed it wasn't even real and then it
killed them they're in the the the bed
be
like and it's a country we can't even
appreciate irony anymore that's the sad
thing we can't appreciate irony we're
all getting too dumb to even know what
it is and we're all becoming such
fundamentalists there's no irony in Iran
for example amongst the people that are
all you know there's no irony amongst
the mullers certainly there's maybe some
irony in the population if they can get
away with it but that's what happens
when you become a fundamentalist
country you know you basically don't
understand irony you don't you don't
understand that concept but it's got to
be ironic to be tied up in a in in a
home in La
while people go rans sack through your
things I mean there's something funny
about that you
know has to be slightly
ironic to be the principal of a
school uh that probably supported this
reform as you know I'm sure there's many
good reasons to support it and then the
father comes in and starts pistol
whipping the
kids there's got to be a an irony there
you have to enjoy it you have to enjoy
it a little bit you have to enjoy it
irony should be like you don't want to
poison yourself with it where you become
just this weird
freak a lot of irony poisoning in the
mid 2000s at places like Brooklyn and
Echo Park we get it too much of it's a
bad thing like the churo frappe but a
little of it is healthy a little of it
is nice it's tasty have a little bit of
it you get a little high you try it out
oh this is what people there's a little
bit of it that I think is nice and it
shows that you're not a fundamentalist
psychopath that you and kind of go well
you know well
hey hey I guess you know I Now
understand some of those things I didn't
understand I have a little understanding
now not a great one you know you know
it's
ironic that uh Panera killed someone
with their lemonade
recently and McDonald's goes we'll kill
a lot more
people Panera killed someone with with
this caffeinated lemonade they have some
poor guy with a disorder went and he had
a couple of these Panera lemonades and
just exploded he was sitting there in
the suburbs and this poor guy
exploded they faced second wrongful
death lawsuit over caade charged
lemonade this is the second person that
paner has taken down with their charged
lemonade
sad the lawsuit alleges Panera knew or
should have known that charged lemonade
could pose risks particularly to
Children pregnant breastfeeding women
and individuals sensitive to caffeine
charged lemonade which has more caffeine
in its large size than 12 ounce Red Bull
and 16 oun Monster Energy combined wow
has been the center of legal scrutiny
for I like this Panero by the way which
is a basic [__] soup restaurant is like
we got to get people zooted we got to
get people
jacked jacked
the lawsuit filed in Delaware disclosed
that brown had ordered Panera's charge
lemonade at least seven times over the
course of two weeks in September and
October and that was it that was the
last thing that [__] did on this
floating Rock was get that charged
lemonade from Panera 7even [__]
times that's what I mean when I say
these places are trying to kill you I'm
not being hyperbolic they genuinely are
but McDonald's is where is Panera will
do you know a person here and there
McDonald's is in it for the long haul K
MC's I don't know if it'll succeed or
not but it might I don't
know um they're in it for the long haul
you know so much of me as in closing has
been thinking recently about Tik
Tock
about so much of what I've thought of as
I've done this show for many years and
as I've paid attention to culture very
closely I pay attention to the beginning
and the end
things I pay attention to how things
start versus how they
finish where they started Facebook
college kids trying to [__] how the
beginning now people that went to
January 6 sharing casserole recipes
whatever it is it's not what it was we
could admit that you know Instagram in
the beginning look it's my family you
know now it's like you know we know what
Instagram is it's like you know get the
tits out do plastic surgery on your face
with the filters try out the person
you'd like to be present the life that
isn't yours but you'd like people to
believe you're having we know Tik Tok
started out as a dancing app from China
it was called musicly and that became
Tik Tock where people
minded the uh hot
songs they would dance and come up with
dances the dances would go viral now it
is a place where people are watching
babies and Gaza get pulled out of
rubble it's what a journey that has been
this is why Israel is losing support
right now because it's like you can't
kill people every day all day on a
children's dancing app if we had Tik
Tock during The Surge of Fallujah people
would be like what are you doing stop
doing this and then we'd go no no no you
don't understand it's it's a preemptive
because if we didn't then you would
democracy and and people go no no no we
don't care well we we just see blood
every day we see blood in every single
day and it doesn't work anymore you
can't kill people in Mass on a
children's dancing
app these young kids are looking at it
go what the
[__] we're like Charlie demilio used to
just we used to Just Dance why is
everybody dead
now why is everybody dead it's blood the
whole algor gorithm is blood now it used
to be fun it used to be the Renegade
remember Addison Ray Renegade Renegade
now it's just bomb blood bomb blood it's
a lot it's a lot but it teaches those
kids an important lesson that is just
the trajectory of any app any social
media
app starts Renegade Ren and ends
genocide genocide
any app
anyone they all have their different
ways of
course you
know Instagram is the genocide of
people's self-respect and
dignity gen Facebook is the genocide of
their mental capacity and Tik Tock is
just here it is here we
are lot of
death and that's what's interesting
about the the journey from where that
app started to where it is now and I
don't know where it goes I don't know
where it goes but I know that it it's
not going to be the same for the people
that have enjoyed it it's not going to
be the same all the families were
together in their pajamas doing the
dance and
everybody's and now you're watching
Carnage from another part of the world
and you're seeing up close
really terrible tragic scenes everywhere
you're seeing Israeli hostages and
tunnels you're seeing uh the murder of
civilians in Gaza you're seeing all of
this
stuff on the app now and it's ch I bet I
bet it's I bet a few kids have been
changed by it they're a little changed
and they're gonna go
[__] and and Cosmic is hoping that those
kids
sit with a
churro Island pear limeade spice crunch
WAP latte whatever the hell they're
doing and and just watch
death in the in the cosmics parking lot
that's the hope that's the hope the hope
is that we can eventually just take the
two most addictive things
sugar and algorithms and merge them so
you just all you do your entire life is
just is churo
frae and Death on Tik Tock and you just
churro frae death on Tik Tock death on
Tik Tock death on Tik Tock [__] limeade
death on Tik Tock popping pear slush
Hunter Biden is being treated unfairly
death on Tik Tock churo fromit and and
that'll be that'll be it that'll be it
that's that's that's what they want
those are the two most most powerful
forces in American Life the consumption
of drugs and the consumption of media
drugs being food alcohol pills whatever
the two most powerful forces in the
American Life are drugs and media and
they want you consuming them together
slushy
beheading
churro death that's what they want so
with
that we we wish you merry merry holidays
merry merry Christmas happy Hanukkah if
you're celebrating
Hanukkah happy Quanza happy Ramadan when
is
Ramadan who cares happy of it happy
everybody happy everybody and go and get
some get some get some get a nice Fried
Chicken uh churro hot chocolate or
whatever McDonald's is going to come up
but go get that go get that poison go
get that poison and then have a little
sneaky uh go go watch a little Tik Tok
I'm really excited about the first thing
I'm going to try is the churo frappe but
I don't know about you you might want
the tropical spiced uh or the turmeric
spice latte
Indians or you might want a berry
habiscus sour
Aid I don't know who's drinking the
s'mores cold brew if you're drinking the
s'mores cold
brew now by the way how soon is it until
you you have people walking through the
Hamas tunnels with these now Israel's
flooded all the Hamas tunnels and that's
unfortunate
but Hamas used to have these tunnels to
get fast food so they would they want
they want KFC they want things they
can't get in Gaza so we know we're
living in a truly globalized World we'll
know it Tom fredman thank you very much
sir we'll know we're living in a truly
globalized world when you see a Hamas
guy and then there are hostages behind
him and it's in a dark tunnel and on the
edge of the desk you go is that a true
frae